hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
antigen-specific cd4 t-cell responses
in humans stars kobe 2 and beyond
i am michelle ashton of labruz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and brought to you by miltoni biotech we
encourage you to participate today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
alexander
alexander sheffield director institute
of immunology
kiel university in germany and dr felix
eckler
global product manager cell sorting at
milton biotech
dr shuffled and dr eppler you may now
begin your presentations
hello and welcome from my site to
today's webinar
my name is felix eppler i'm product
manager for
cell sorting solutions here at miltoni
biotech
and in today's webinar we would like to
address the question whether the common
cold
coronavirus is either a protector from
or rather an exacerbator of covet 19.
our webinar will be split into two parts
today
first i will talk about a technical
highlight the max quantity cell sorter
the system which allows for aerosol free
and gentle cell sorting in a closed
cartridge system
and in the second part alexander
sheffield from the university of kiel
we'll talk about a study he and his
group conducted recently
and focus on antigen-specific cd4
positive t-cell responses in humans
and thereby on sask of 2 and beyond
so let's start with a technical
introduction let's have a closer look
to the max quantitative cell sorter
but before we do so i would like to give
you a short overview
on the general product portfolio at
miltoni biotech
as you can see we try to cover whole
workflows
starting with sample preparation
including
subsequent cell isolation or cell
sorting
cell culture and cell activation and
expansion possibilities
but then also send a cell analysis using
flow cytometry as well as
microscopy in an ideal world
these workflows then can be easily
translated
into the clinical segments so from
benchtop to bedside
and this is also something we are
focusing on here at
miltoni biotech
since we're talking about corona viruses
today i'd also like to take
the opportunity to shortly
highlight a few of our products
which help researchers around the world
in order to understand
the saskof2 in much more detail and
these are different
reagents for example our saskov2
peptivata peptide pools
or the sask of two antigens but also
analysis kits and sorting kits for
example for sask of two specific
b and t cells and of course there's
specific instrumentation supporting
these researchers
and one of them as said before is the
max quantity cell soda
which i will focus on in the following
few slides
if we talk about flow cytometry based
cell sorting most of the people
think about facts droplet sorters these
are the systems which you mainly
find in the laboratories and core
facilities
if we talk about sorting of infectious
material these systems
come with a few problems and that is the
first that
they are open system and produce
droplets as well as
aerosols in an open space but they also
share their fluidics and tubings and for
most of the systems it's very difficult
to exchange those and this means that a
lot of
yeah very difficult and
time-consuming decontamination processes
are needed
in between samples last but not least
if you're thinking about going into
delicate
downstream analysis of the cells for
example cell
single cell genomics but also functional
analysis
a problem can also be that the sorting
process itself
on droplet sorters can be very harsh and
depending on your cell
type create problems with downstream
functionality or also
artifacts in your analysis
and we think that we have a very good
alternative to conventional
droplet-based systems
with the maxq1 title cell sorter
the maxwell title is a benchtop sized
cell sorter
allowing for a controlled sample
temperature between 4 and 25 degrees of
celsius
and there are no external fluidics so
really what you
place into your laboratory is what you
can see here on this picture
the title comes with three different
lasers eight fluorescence channels and
four scatter channels and there allows
for quite some flexibility
in terms of antibody panel design
the heart of the system is the max1
tidal cartridge
which has three different chambers an
input chamber where the sample of
interest goes into
a positive collection chamber where the
target cells will end up after the
sorting procedure
and a negative collection chamber where
all the rest will simply flow into
cell sorting as well as analysis take
place at a small microchip at the bottom
of the cartridge
which is depicted in this picture here
just for your understanding how small
the microchip really is
i'd like to show you this size
comparison here
so in order to understand its
architecture a little bit better we need
to zoom in
and here you can already see the
channels which directly connect the
microchip
with the different chambers of the
cartridge if we zoom in again
we see the architecture of the chip you
can see different
channels and the cells coming from the
input chamber
enter the microchip at the lower left
hand side
and then run through the sorting chain
where the cells are analyzed
and if a if a target cell is identified
the sorting procedure will be initiated
and the sorting procedure itself will be
carried out
with a very fast micro valve we can also
have a closer look
to this procedure
so here you can see the micro valve
which is actually opened by a magnetic
pulse coming from a solenoid
one opening and closing cycle takes
around 30 microseconds
which allows for up to 30 000 micro
valve openings and closings per second
you can see an animation of the sorting
mechanism itself
cells coming from the input chamber past
the three different lasers
and in case of positive target cells has
been identified
a magnetic pulse opens the micro valve
which then
very gently redirects the cells into
another channel
leading into the positive collection
chamber all the rest flows through
into the negative collection chamber
the only thing coming in and getting out
of the cartridge during the sorting
process is sterile filtered air
it enters the cartridge at its bottom
through an 0.1 micrometer hydrophobic
filter
and then before entering the input
chamber once again
through another 0.1 micrometer
hydrophobic filter
ensuring sterility of the air before
entering the input chamber
also the ventilation ports at the
positive as well as the negative
collection chambers
are covered with those hydrophobic 0.1
micrometer
filters
an interesting study coming from
different groups at the national
institute of health and usa
which has been recently published in
applied biosafety validated the
application of the max quantitative cell
sorter
in a bsl3 containment setting
so what did the authors do in the study
they used fluorescent beats and sorted
them either on the max1 title
or in a bdfx area 2 with the aerosol
management system disabled
and then use the gold standard for
detection of aerosolization of
instruments
cyclexd impactors in order to check
whether aerosols
and thereby also fluorescent beads had
been released from the systems during
the sorting process
as you can see on the right hand side
the fox area 2 with its aerosol
management system disabled
released a lot of fluorescent beads
which is a strong indicator for strong
aerosolization
during the sorting process in contrast
the max quantity did not release any
aerosols at all during the sorting
process
also not once the cartridge was opened
post sorting
the authors concluded that this
instrument is not only
suitable for bsl3 due to its small
footprint
but most importantly because it does not
generate aerosols during the sorting
procedure
so let's shortly sum up where are the
benefits of using the max current title
for sorting off infectious material
we have a closed and sterile sorting
environment
and no sample to sample carryover as
there are no
internal fluidics or tubings present in
the system
if you use a new cartridge you always
use a completely new
fluidic system there are also no
contamination
and therefore also no decontamination
processes
needed in between samples and most
importantly
no aerosols are produced with a
microwave mediated sorting process
but it's not only about safety it's also
about the gentleness
of the maxcon tidal it operates at very
low pressure
and therefore the cells do not
experience any decompression or
charge and also only encounter mild
shear forces
which is of course very important for
delicate downstream
analysis of functional essays
which are conducted post sorting
one of these delicate downstream
analysis which is in a strong need
for high quality samples and therefore
also for gentle
cell sorting technologies or in general
gentle
sample preparation technologies is
the genomics analysis of cells for
example if you're interested in
transcriptomics as you can see on the
right hand side in a direct comparison
between epithelial cells and their
transcriptomics
after they have been sorted either using
the maxcon title or
conventional droplet sorter you can see
that
certain signaling pathways directly
connected to stress
such as apoptosis mitochondrial genes or
oxidative stress that these are higher
and stronger expressed in the cells
which had been
sorted using the droplet sorter so it
really is key
what kind of technology you use and it
will influence the data
you will receive in the end if you're
interested in more details on
this application and the background of
the study
then please have a look at another
webinar from our site realize better ngs
results through gentle cell sorting
this is available at the miltoni biotech
website as well as here
on lab roots and with that i'm really
happy to
hand over to professor dr alexander
sheffeld
as said he's the director at the
institute of immunology
um at the keele university in germany
and today
he'll discuss the antigen specific cd4
t t-cell response of saskoff two
patients
and their connection to the cold
coronavirus
and with that i'm already looking
forward to listen to your talk alexander
and yeah thank you for your attention
welcome to my talk about suscob2
specific c default t
cell responses in healthy donors and
kobe 19. my name is alexander scheffert
and
i'm the head of the institute of
immunology at the christians alberts
university
in kier
so we still don't understand many
aspects of kovic 19
and for example one uh striking question
is why do some people develop
severe kobe 19 whereas others
remain for example completely
asymptomatic
so the there is the idea that adaptive
immune
responses play a key role in that
process so they could be
too little or too strong or just
inappropriate
responses on the other hand there's the
question whether pre-existing immune
memory
could have an influence either
protective but maybe even harmful
so the characterization of cytoskovie
two specific t
helper cells which are actually
orchestrating the adaptive immune
response
is one of the key aspects of analyzing
the adaptive
immunity so one can look on the
frequencies on the phenotypes
also under antigenic targets and but
also looking on the functionality of
these cells
such as tcr specificities and cross
reactivities
but also the tcr affinities and
clonality
antigen-specific t-cells can be
identified in
two different ways so either by direct
staining with the ligand this is the
peptide
mhc molecule and this allows direct
labeling
of the antigen-specific t-cell receptors
and then these label cells can be
identified by a conventional flow
cytometry
this is the only way of direct tcr
labeling
but it requires that we have exactly
defined mhc and peptide complexes
which need to be prepared and
so far my the main analysis is still
done in cd8 t cells
a classical way of detecting tesla
reactivity is by a functional assay so
the idea is just to add
the antigen to a solute to a suspension
of antigen percentage cells
together with t cells the apc take up
the antigen process the antigen and
present the peptides on the mhc
molecules
and then the antigen specific t cells
get
activated and start to react with a
defined set of effective functions
including
rapid cytokine production expression of
certain so-called activation markers on
the
surface or after a longer
time of simulation proliferation occurs
in our hands the the activation markers
cd 154
and cd 137 have been particularly useful
because they require minimal
manipulation of only seven hours in
vitro
re-stimulation they can be used to
detect
basically all pathogens and antigens
ranging from peptide pools antigen
lysates or recombinant proteins
of course this is possible in all donors
because we have no mhc
restriction and all t helper subsets
somehow upregulate one of these markers
including the
fox p3 positive regulatory t cells
so for some general questions regarding
antigen-specific cytometry i
would like to recommend this article in
the european
journal of pharmacology this is a
general guidelines
for flow cytometry covering basically
everything you can do with flow
cytometry and cell sorting
and this also includes an overview about
the different
technologies which can be used to
identify antigen-specific
b and t cells via cytometry
and the technical aspect in that case
has a considerable
impact on the interpretation of the data
actually
so one general problem of antigen
specific cytometry
cytometry is that these cells are
typically very rare and here i just
show a couple of examples this is a
cd154 based stimulation based assay
detecting cd154 and reactive cells so
this is very low background without
without a stipulation
and here's some classical pathogens and
you can already see that
typically the frequency of cells is way
below one percent
in some cases even below 0.1 percent
that is summarized below here in that
cartoon where you can see that the
frequencies are really
one in 1 000 or even less in case of
alternations or naive tissue repertoire
so the the technology we use for
identification of antigen-specific t
cells is also based on this in vitro
activation with antigen
for five to seven hours and that leads
to up regulation of these two molecules
on a cell surface of activated
t cells regulatory t cells make cd137
conventional t cells in xcd1 54 to c40
ligand
and here you can directly see the
frequencies are really low
about 0.1 0.2 percent
so what we did we combined this
techno detection technology with a
magnetic filtration step
allowing to separate the rare reactive
cells from a large population of cells
10 to hundreds of millions of cell pvmcs
and we can filter out the few reactive
cells and this
gives then a sizeable population of
regulatory t cells shown here in blue
the conventional t cells and
one can now do a really in-depth
analysis
of these rare reactive cells looking
also on the quality so
on the phenotype the function the tcr
affinity cytokine production and to also
kind
all kinds of omics technologies due to
the
purification of these cells
so when we applied this technology to
blood samples of covet 19 patients we
got quite striking responses as shown
here in covet 19.
so the main reactivity was that directed
against the
classical targets spike membrane and
m-protein
but also summary activities against
other proteins were identified
interestingly when we looked at
unexposed donors we also saw basically
in every
page in every donor we found cytoscopy
two reactive t
cells or also distributed
against various antigens and this is
summarized here showing that although
there is a clear-cut difference
in the frequencies of oscilloscope 2
reactive t
cells in cobit 19 versus healthy
unexposed
basically in every donor we were still
able to identify
the south cov2 reactive t cells and that
is just influenza as a controller
there's no difference between patients
and healthy
one can summarize that so the radish
labels is indicating the two three main
targets
spike m and n protein and this is these
are the main
targets especially in copic 19 patients
in infected patients
whereas in unexposed it's more scattered
there are considerable
variabilities so in some donors also
other proteins
are the major targets so to summarize
that
sm and n protein are the main targets in
covid19
there are more diverse targets in
unexposed donors
but in general pre-existing memory t
cells
can be detected in all unexposed donors
so now of course the the question is are
these really
cells cov2 specific t cells we are
detecting here and
this is now showing the original data
this is after stimulation before
enrichment there's a low frequency of
reactive cells in a copic 19 patient
and this now shows the dramatic
enrichment
of a lot of reactive cells
by magnetic cell sorting and the same is
actually true in unexposed donors
although we can clearly see
that here we have much less reactive
cells but still we get a considerable
enrichment of these cells from the
unexposed donor so are they specific
we tested this by generating
in vitro expanded t cell lines from
these enriched cells
and then re-simulated them with the
cytoscopy ii or control antigens and as
you can beautifully see
in kobit 19 as well as in unexposed
donors
these t cell lines exclusively react to
the inducing
inducing antigen but not the control
antigen as you can already see here
in the unexposed donors there's this
kind of a higher
background reactivity against the other
antigens
as compared to kobit 19 whereas the
background is almost
zero i will come back to that later on
so we were wondering about this
pre-existing t-cell immunity
and there was the hypothesis that this
might be induced by cross-activity to
common cold corona viruses which are
causing um the common cold in in healthy
in normal people and and the idea was
that maybe
children because they are frequently
infected with these
common cold viruses are better protected
from south korea too as compared to
elderly
because some of these related antigens
cause cross-reactive protective immunity
so as i said we can detect these antigen
specific cells in all unexposed donors
but when we looked at the phenotype
there was a clear-cut difference so
whereas in covid19 patients there were
no naive t cells as indicated here by
cd45ra and ccr7 expression
as expected for can for a memory
in vivo memory t service bonds however
in unexposed donors
these cells could be two specific cells
there was a considerable fraction of
naive t cells and that was
actually true in all unexposed donors so
it's a highly variable
amount of memory versus naive
t cells and these unexposed donors
against basically all
three main target proteins and again
the control influenza you as you expect
for a memory
response they are made mainly comprised
of memory cells
in unexposed as well as in kobit 19
patients and
most strikingly again copy 19 patients
the sales copy 2 specific t cells were
almost
completely to one uh to almost 100
of a memory phenotype so this already
suggested that
um there's a significant um
heterogeneity in of memory and naive
t cells so the question is what is the
reason for that is that due to cross
reactivity or is
or is that a general phenomenon within
the
within the total t cell subsets
and so we just ahead or just want to
show some data
on the total cd4 repertoire because
as we know the aging has a significant
impact on
immune repertoire and that is shown here
for two examples this is a young donor
and an
old donor and this is just looking here
on cd45ra ccr7 again so we see in the
young donor we
have a 70 of naive t cells
whereas in the old donor there are just
seven percent of naive t
cells and now interestingly when we now
enrich the south kovi two specific t
cells and these are both unexposed
donors
and when we now analyze these cytoscopy
two reactive t cells we realize that
also here the young donor seventy
percent of the cells cov2 specific
t-cells were also naive
versus in the old donor there were
almost no naive t
cells in the cells called two reactive
cells
and we can plot that and that is
indicating actually that
it is just a linear almost linear
correlation between the
total frequency of memory cells within
the cd4 compartment
which we call the immunological age or
the immunological
experience increasing memory
frequencies and this is this is linearly
correlated with the frequency of memory
cells in the cells kobe 2 specific
t cells so indicating that this is not
due to a particular pre-infection with a
particular virus but it's
more or less a function of the general
broad memory t cell repertoire which is
increasing
in healthy people within it by by aging
and that is actually not restricted to
cells copy 2 we see exactly the same
linear correlationship in cmv
negative donors against the so also the
cmv
specific t-cells have exactly the same
shape and again
against the complete narrow antigen the
keyhole lymphatic hemocyanins
klh we see the same effect and again
when we look then
as a comparison in cmv exposed or sales
kobe 2 exposed
donors there's clear-cut a pure
memory phenotype due to the in vivo
activation and expansion and memory
formation due to them
in vivo infection so this is actually
indicating that the south copy kov2
pre-existing memory correlates
simply with the size of the total memory
pool which we call
also the immunological age
and now the question is do these
pre-existing memory cells differ
from the cell the memory cells we found
in the core v19 patients
so what the next we did we looked on the
functional ability of this cell so we
took specific t
cell lines generated from unexposed or
in copy 19 patients and re-stimulate
these cells with graded peptidosis and
as you can nicely see
in unexposed donors you need extremely
high concentration up to 0.5 microgram
per ml to get a response
whereas in copic 19 patients the t cells
react already at the lowest those 0.001
microgram of peptide and you can
calculate from that the ec 50 values and
as you can see although
not all corvid 19 patients
develop high affinity responses but at
least some of them do
whereas in healthy people so the
unexposed
the pre-existing memory cells they are
all exclusively
of low avidity responses
so to summarize that the pre-existing
cells cov2 memory t-sets are present in
all unexposed individuals analyzed
they have low ability for sales cov2
and basically this frequency of
pre-existing memory correlates simply
with the size of the total memory pool
which is the immunological age or the
immunological experience
so the next important question was now
but still do we see some induction of
these cross reactivity by
common cold corona virus
so uh we analyzed also the response to
the four
known members so of these common cold
coronavirus trains and what we found is
that all tested donors had extremely
high frequencies of reactive cells
and they were of a complete memory
phenotype indicating really in vivo
selection expansion and memory formation
against these viruses
and that is in striking contrast to the
cells kobe 2
response in these these very same donors
and then and then had a closer look as
expected
for a real infection the common cold
corona virus specific t cells
were all of a relatively high ability
again in contrast to the telescopic tube
of these unexposed donors
and finally we also had the chance to
look here on the cross reactivity
so we took the common cold corona virus
specific
t cell lines and stimulated them either
with the inducing antigen and we got
higher reactivities or we re-stimulated
with the cell scope 2 and there was
almost no reactivity detectable
so basically what we found is that we
find high ability and expanded
memory t cells against the common cold
coronavirus
in virtually all tested donors
however almost no cross reactivity
between
these specific t cells and the cells
cov2 antigen
the next was then to check whether these
salisco v2 reactive t cells contain some
cross reactivity and that is
ex first we looked here on the unexposed
donors
and doing exactly the same experiment
reassimilation of cells could be two
specific t
cells with different types of antigens
they have high reactivity against
against the three different antigens we
use for the generation
however they have also brought cross
reactivity against a number of
different antigens but that is not only
restricted to the common cold
coronavirus
but it's also seen against other viruses
like influenza cmv evb and adenovirus so
indicating that this crossroad activity
is not restricted to a particular
antigen or virus and the next
was then to look in covid19 patient and
the result was quite striking
whereas we still see high reactivities
against the three main targets
basically these cross reactive cells are
hardly detectable
in coping 19 patients indicating that
upon in vivo infection there's a
positive selection of
cells kobe 2 specific high ability cells
and a negative selection for these
low-ability cross-reactive cells and
that can be quantitated
by looking on the percent of cross
reactivity in each t cell line
and it is clear that is very high in the
unexposed but it's almost completely
lost in the covet 19 situation showing
this clear-cut evidence for selection of
high ability monospecific cells
during the covet 19 infection
so the the human coronavirus
cross-reactive cells although they are
present
they do not really contribute to the
code 2 response
in copy 19 infection and that was
actually beautifully
confirmed in a recent study where they
really analyzed
or identified t-cell receptors which
cross-reacted
especially against the homologous
peptide
uh between cytoscopy and the common
corona called corona virus
which is frequently identified in in
unexposed donors
and the the the this work here i
cloned cross-reactive tcr's and showed
that
these cloned tdrs really have low
ability
low proliferative capacity against
telescope 2
as compared to the original common cold
coronavirus peptide
so this con nicely confirms that the
pre-existing
common code coronavirus reactive
cross-reactive memory cells
poorly react against the cells cov2
protein and therefore are probably not
relevant or are at least not
protective in a situation of cell scope
to infection
and i just here want to point out that
this antigen-specific hydrometry is
really helpful also to improve
single cell or in general or mix
data which are frequently used nowadays
to look on the whole blood however and
also do tcr sequencing on
on that level however we should not
forget that so far it is
not possible to extract from the tcr
sequence
the specificity so by combination of
global single cell sequencing
together with sequencing of in
individual
sorted antigen specific b or t cells and
identification of these tcr's
in the antigen specific subsets one can
add
the specificity and the function into
these
global t single cell
rna profiling experiments and
that is actually what we what we did
so we we under identified
the antigen specific t cells in zero
score we do in kobit 19 patients
we did the rt technology and then we
made use here of this beautiful glow
system with a clinimax title
and sorted these reactive cells to
really high purity
which allows us then to do functional
assays but also single cell
rna profiling and this the idea was here
to look whether we see differences
between patients with mild disease
versus severe disease and the first
striking observation was
then we when we looked on moderate and
severe
19 patients we found that those actually
have
strongly increased frequency of reactive
cells so it's not an
impaired immune reactivity in the cells
as it was previously reported with other
methods
however the really striking result came
when we also now looked on the ability
of these t-cell responses and what we
found is that
in in non-hospitalized patients they had
a strikingly high ability response
suggesting a good selection of high
affinity tcrs during infection
whereas in a hospitalized patients the
ability was similar to the unexposed
indicating that under these conditions
although the response is very strong
the t cells are sub-optimal because they
only react
to cells copy 2 with a very low affinity
and then we also did a single cell
sequencing
and identified the tcr profiles of these
x vivo isolated cytoscopy 2 t cells to
look
on the clonality of the response and
what we
can see here that in again
in hospitalized patients there's a very
high diversity
indicating that there's no clonal or
only weak
clonal selection upon infection whereas
in non-hospitalized
patients the diversity was much lower
indicating
really a selection of individual high
affinity clones and that is also
somehow reflected here when we look on
the different
subpopulations within the antigen
reactive t cells and here just look
under
in black the top three expanded clones
and you can see here that they are all
collected here in one particular subset
which is actually characterized by high
higher activity whereas in severe
disease
there is not such an accumulation so
there are scattered all over the place
and found in all different
subsets which were identified in this
experiment
so this is um actually indicating that
this is a strong but an
unfocused and low ability safety for t
cell response in cv ecobid19
and now of course the question is does
the pre-existing memory which has also
this low affinity contribute to such a
low ability response in severe coping 19
patients and we could not completely
address this because we had no samples
before and after
infection however we tried to to filter
that out of our data by
looking only on a patient group
with the age between 50 and 65
and when we looked on them we still see
the same phenomenon severe patients
have still high frequencies of
antigen-reactive cells
however it was interesting to observe
when we
now look on the immunological age of
these patients so that just
looking on the frequency of memory cells
in the total city
cells we see that the severe patients
have much higher
immunological experience or age as
compared to the non-hospitalized
versus in healthy there is a classical
broad distribution of all memory
frequencies so this is at least
suggesting that
patients with severe disease have a
higher immunological age and this might
actually contribute
to the development of a poor antigen
specific response upon infection
so to summarize that increased
frequencies of cell scope 2 specific t
cells are found in severe copic 19 and
this is independent of age
they the increased immunological age
correlates with covid19
severity in this age group uh and
we still have to do analysis of pair
samples before and
after vaccination that is now much more
easy
than with natural infection that is
ongoing
but i just want to show you a couple of
uh or the first results on vaccination
so that is just
showing the frequencies so
pre-vaccination
level and we see a very strong induction
of cells kobe 2
reactive t cells upon two times
vaccination
and now again the interesting part is
again the young and old donor i showed
you before so the one which has this
large fraction of naive t cells in the
cytoscopy ii reactive t
cells versus the old donor which had who
has almost no naive t
cells in the cytoskeleto before
vaccination
and if you now look at just on these two
donors on the response
you see that the young donor
had a very low starting level but has a
dramatic increase
of reactive t cells whereas the old
donor has a higher starting level of
memory cells but has
only a very mild increase upon
vaccination suggesting that the
older patient reacts poorly against the
vaccination and that is actually true
for the for a number of donors as shown
here
so there's a beautiful negative linear
correlation
of the the more memory frequency
memory t cells we have pre-vaccination
the lower is the fold expansion in
response to vaccination and the same can
be done with
just looking at the frequency of memory
cells in the total cd4
so the immunological age and that also
has a negative
linear correlation with the fold
expansion indicating that
the more memory cells we have against
cells cov2
or in total the lower is the reaction to
the vaccine
so to summarize that so i said i wanted
to make the point that the analysis of
the rare antigen-specific lymphocytes
is really an important tool to better
understand protective and also
pathogenic immune responses
and you should not forget that it's just
much less than one percent of all cd4 t
cells but they make the difference
in such antigen-specific diseases
and pre-existing cytoscopy two reactive
memory t
cells are really present in all humans
but
they have only low functional ability
and they have broad target specificities
on the other hand human coronavirus the
common cold coronavirus
they are also very abundant but they do
not strongly contribute
to the south kobe 2 response following
infection
and finally the most interesting result
probably is that
in severe cobit 19 patients we see a
very strong response but this is a
very poor quality indicated by low
ability and polyclonality
against cytoscopy ii and and
we we can also show that the expanded
pre-existing memory
correlates with the weak response to
vaccination
so in general the last comment to
pre-existing or cross-reactive
memory and human t-cell responses and
aging so it seems that
there is a correlation of the size of
the cd4
memory compartment which is
somehow related to the immunological age
and this seems to be a risk factor for
to develop severe coping 19 this we
still have to show
but we can already we have already
indication that it correlates with a
weak response to
vaccination and that will be um analyzed
in the in the future by our group
so at the last point i want to to thank
the people involved so the major
contribution is by peter she was mainly
responsible for this for planning and uh
and organizing this this study together
with member of
members of her group gabriela rios
martinez together with
members of my own group the ekmb in kiel
doing the single cell sequencing
analysis
and then we have a lot of clinical
cooperation partners especially the
people from the hospital
university hospital in cologne and also
also in the hospital
in frankfurt who contributed a lot of
clinical samples necessary for doing
this analysis
thank you very much and i'm happy to
answer your questions
thank you alexander and felix for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for all right let's go
ahead and get started
our first question is
are there different types of cartridges
available
for the taito sorter
so maybe i can take this question thank
you um
very much a very interesting question
and indeed um
there are different cartridge types so
um i included our
conventional standard research use only
cartridge
in my presentation here the same
cartridge design
is also available in max gmp
format if you're planning to go into
clinical
applications or working in translational
environments
and we also have a high speed cartridge
which
runs at double the speed um therefore
allows for a
higher cellular processing
in the same amount of time and this
also comes with an additional feature
which is inertial focusing of the cells
so you will also have a very good
resolution inside the sorting channel
which is comparable to the hydrodynamic
focusing
found in dropper-based systems so there
are actually
different carriage types yes and the
high-speed cartridge also will
soon be launched in the gmp compliant
formers
thank you felix okay our next question
what does the system separate during
testing of stars kobe 2
and how long can a microchip be used
so um as we're talking um about a
self-sorting system here we are
um obviously sorting mainly cells
um in terms of starscop2 we see
actually different applications here in
this example
alexander was presenting we saw that it
was about
ce for positive t cells expressing
certain markers
and they had also been specific for
certain kinds of viruses we also know
about for example saskof2
specific b cells which have been sorted
also dendritic cells from copper 19
patients
but of course you're not only limited to
cells you can also sort
um other organisms such as bacteria or
yeast
or we also know of researchers
using the title for sorting of
sporozoites
of plasmodium for example
so there's actually a very
different applications possible but in
this case it had been about the
sorting of cells and concerning the
microchip a part of the question
so the microchip is part of these
single-use disposable cartridges
you of course can use
this cartridges for up to
500 million cells which can be loaded
inside of 10 milliliters into
this coverage type and sold them but
as that the carriages are single-use
disposables and if you use the new
cartridge you'll also
automatically use a new microchip
hey great thank you uh do you know if
b-cell response
is similar
so maybe it's a question for me so um
we have not we have not looked in detail
on the visa response we have just looked
on the antibody response but
overall in the literary literature my my
um
my um understanding is that
basically everybody develops a beautiful
strong
visa response and there is no not such a
thing like
low of low ability or low affinity
responses
thank you alexander okay our next
question
can we correlate with antigenic sin two
um with the antigenic sin yeah um
so basically yeah that was that is
actually the original
idea that a previous infection leaves a
footprint
in the immune response and then
a second infection with um with a
similar peptide is influenced by this
primary infection
so basically what we are describing is a
kind of a
antigenic sin but we see it as a more
broader
um phenomenon of
that in general a large memory
repertoire as we find it in human
especially in the in older humans
um has a basically a a
large repertoire for new antigens so
basically um
any new epitope will
lead to a reactivity of some
pre-existing memory t cells and it and
in general i think it will be really
important to study that in the future
because that is a
very big difference between laboratory
mice
and humans and i think it has a very
strong influence and now
i think this south korea ii pandemic um
is teaching us that this might have a
strong impact and we see it all in
vaccinations so i think this is really
something
looking uh for especially in the human
system and also
the effect of aging
thank you alexander okay our next
question it looks like it might be for
you felix
how many sorting can be done in a single
title system without
changing either the cartridge or the
microchip
yeah so um the cartridge input chamber
has a volume of
10 milliliters and you go can go up to
50 million
cells per milliliter which makes up to
500
million cells you can load into a
cartridge of course depends on your
application
on target cell frequency and on your
expectations on
yields and purity and what cell
concentration
you want to sort but that is what is
possible
with one single cartridge and uh
yeah i said the nice thing is that um
the system
the fluidic system is really completely
contained inside the cartridge so
if you exchange that you will also
exchange the fluidic system
and um yeah this is this is what's
possible
within one cartridge and therefore also
one microchip
okay great thank you okay our next
question
have you identified the sars cov2
signals
in the t cells scrna data
um i'm not completely sure whether you
mean that we
whether we identified viral viral
sequences in the in
the cd4 teasers no so they were they
were not
infected also we did not see any
infected
so that was the question
great thank you okay our next question
does how does the taito cartridge
compare
to a biosafety cabinet frequently used
for self orders
so that's also a very good question
since
once you're interested in sorting in
fact material using
open systems producing aerosols and
droplets
you need to do that inside a biosafety
cabinet those are
most of the time very large
instrumentations quite expensive
um space consuming um and
these um yeah biosafety cabinets they
most of the time work with heap filters
and deeper filters have
four sizes of 0.1 to 0.3 micrometers
and with the pore size and
inside the sterile and hydrophobic
membranes
we use inside the microcontroller
cartridges 0.1
micrometer pore sizes we are actually at
the same
range as these deeper filters so it's
actually quite comparable and currently
we are also looking into
possibilities to even lower the pore
size
of the filters used inside the cartridge
because
obviously the variants for example of
sask of two they they kind of
different sizes different diameters
ranging from 50 nanometers
to 200 nanometers but
the good thing is they are always bound
to
some sort of aerosols and therefore will
also be repelled by the hydrophobic
membrane
but yeah that's that's how those systems
compare
thank you felix okay our next question
which variant
of stars kovi 2 was used to study the
correlation
and can this correlation differ in other
variants of stars kobe 2.
so we used the the the wild type
variance in the first one
which was uh identified and i don't
think
that the the variants have a strong
impact on the t-cell response there are
too many peptides
too many hlas so i i don't think that
an individual mutation um will
have a strong effect and that is also
supported by the data now that
showing actually that the t cell
responses are are equally strong against
the variance
as far as i know it
thank you alexander looks like we have
time for a few more questions here
our next question has the tai cho also
been used
to sort um cd4t
lymphocytes from hiv-positive patients
yes indeed there are also researchers
using
using the instrument in hiv research and
also use it to to sort infected
lymphocytes um
with the hiv virus but also
um yeah as i said before also different
kinds of
infectious materials have been used from
um
yeah samples infected with diverse kinds
of bacteria
viruses but also for example um
parasites parasites themselves so yes
the answers
okay great thank you um now why are
strong yet low
avidity stars kobe 2 t cell responses
unable to clear the virus
despite showing functional parameters of
activation
um yeah that's that's actually not so i
think there are a couple of questions
regarding the
also whether this affects vaccine safety
and so on this
so i think what we have to differentiate
between
um what the t cell responds and the
or the immune response is doing to the
virus so i think
most even in the severe cases they can
control the virus that is not the
problem i think the problem is the
the over-reaction of the immune system
and so this is also what we are
addressing
we think that um i think this is one of
the few examples where we can really
make a point that severe disease is
characterized
by an uh low ability but strongly
expanded
uh antigen specific response and we
think that this is actually contributing
to the immune pathology
but but this does not negatively not
necessarily
negatively affect the virus elimination
so um and and and also the same
is true for the vaccination and so on
although we see a lower response
um and i think the the vaccination is
pretty fine
everybody is developing a strong b cell
antibody response so this is the primary
goal
and also um even a low ability
t cell reaction if it is pre-existing
so before if you have it before
infection is probably helpful against
the virus
the problem is only arising if you i
have a newer infection so if you
the first time meet the virus and then
the cells
obviously the lower ability cells may be
due to this
pre-existing memory they develop into a
huge response
which generates a lot of inflammatory
cytokines and so on
um and and which is maybe also poorly
controlled
due to the low ability that is that is
the idea but i think the protection
is fine so if it's already there you are
protected
the problem is only an infection with a
new virus
well thank you alexander and felix for
your time today
do either of you have any final comments
for our audience before we go today
yeah so i would like to thank the the
the
the audience here for putting all these
questions
and um maybe i i really
want to point out how important it is to
measure to do
to perform these antigen-specific
analysis also
especially in the t-cell field this is
currently not
not in the clinical routine uh but
uh it might turn out that exactly the
knowing exactly the phenotype and the
functional parameters of the
of of the specific teaser response
can really be critical and should be um
should be emphasized in the future and i
think also
it is important to understand that the
techniques used to
to analyze the cells has a very strong
impact and and and that is also
something
the scientific
community should discuss how we should
standardize that that we can make the
results comparable thank you
yeah and also from my side thank you
very much to the audience and for your
interest in that topic and also
thank you alexander for that very nice
presentation
and for all the learnings we got today i
think that was
really really helpful and it's important
work in terms of understanding
saskof2 and yeah our body's reaction to
it in
more detail so thanks for that and
yeah i hope you all enjoyed the webinar
today and
i hope you also learned a little bit on
possibilities in order to safely sort
infectious material if you're
working with such kind of applications
um and that the maximum title is um
always a possibility for aerosol free
self self sorting yeah thank you
thank you again alexander and felix we
would also like to thank labberts
and our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
labyrints will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time goodbye